- Part of our focus in terms of SEL
is to become more aware of
our emotions and reactions.
So Rashad is the character who gets--
- Abused by the police officer
- Do you see these things happening?
- I've seen it happen to others.
- [Narrator] Because our kids
participate in daily advisory
they feel more connected
to our school community,
they feel like they know themselves
and others around them better,
and we have huge accomplishments
in our kids' learning outcomes.
- We're gonna begin just with
two minutes of mindfulness
(chiming)
- [Narrator] The nest
is our daily advisory.
- Think about inhaling and exhaling.
- We're really reflecting
on what we are proud
of about ourselves.
- [Narrator] We're really
focused on two things.
One is literacy.
- Right after this part right here.
- [Narrator] And the other one
is social emotional learning.
- [Student] I know, I did
I was like super excited.
- I really want you to
think on who you are,
what you represent, things
that you're going through.
- At Pearl-Cohn we want to increase
a discussion based classroom.
A class is never going
to look discussion based
if the kids aren't comfortable talking
in front of each other because
they're worried they'll be made fun of
or they're worried that
they'll have the wrong answer.
So we build family mindset,
getting to know each other,
talking through goals,
talking through setbacks.
The good things of life,
the hardships of life.
Y'all just put it in your own words that's
like the best part.
- How I'm supposed to explain something
I don't know how to do?
- We can talk about anything we want,
tell our teacher just everything.
You get to know other students better
and create a bond with each other.
- I'm proud to be a strong woman,
I'm proud of being a volleyball player
and I am proud of Miss
Tilley and her hard work
- And then the second part of the nest
is spent reading a novel together.
- We are going to dig back into this book
- Really great novels lead
to great conversations
and they perfectly align with
social emotional learning.
I believe literacy is a civil
rights issue in this country.
We consider our citizens
literate at ninth grade or higher
and the vast majority of
my kids are below that
and that means they're
not engaging our society,
our democracy in a way that is empowering
and participatory.
So if there is one thing we
put a lot of energy around
it is trying to help
our kids become readers.
- We are reading a book
called All-American Boys.
- I didn't want to hear my father preach
about how young black people lack pride
and integrity and making us easy targets.
- We wanna to broaden kids'
capacity to enjoy reading
by having deep conversations
about the subjects and
themes the kids live out.
- [Student] The first story
was about a kid accused
of stealing from a store on the west side.
- So on the middle of page a hundred
you've got this cop who
represents this abusive authority.
You had a reaction to that.
- People abuse their
authority when they get it.
- [Chad] Conversation
today was about mistrust
between authority and community.
When our kids read that
there's a guttural reaction
that takes place.
- Like, I just got so mad.
This boy, he got beat
up by a police officer.
When I heard that I instantly,
it just draw me into it
because that's something I see,
I go through everyday.
- [Student] Like a lot of this
stuff has actually happened.
- There's a lot of police
brutality going on.
Sometimes it kind of releases some rage.
- That still goes on, I mean...
- [Sonia] So it's access to text
and giving them the ability
to face each other, look
each other in the eye
and have conversations
around significant topics.
- I want to say altercation, but then--
- The nest lays the ground
for academic learning.
It holds kids to higher standards
and to higher expectations.
- It's a time to build community
and to make certain that each kid has
at least one individual in the building
that invests personally
in his or her best.
- [Arshon] Our nest is a family.
- [Chad] Somos familia.
- I feel like I can talk
about anything I need to here.
- We're sitting silently,
we'll start by focusing--
- Looking at the data,
they've grown in learning
and have become people that
are increasingly more aware
of who they are and care for others.
All of that is directly linked
to social emotional learning
and the work that happens in the nest.
- You guys have changed and
grown up so much this year
and I'm so lucky to know you.